[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans cet autre cas dit bonjour marié les
lutins bonjour bertrand caruge bonjour
aux auditeurs et auditrices de la
première martinique
ce matin nous vous recevons entre en
tant que directrice de publication de
apal radio apal le journal apal apal
pour assez pleuré en nullité nous
reviendrons d'ailleurs sur la
signification de cet acronyme mais
pourquoi on en parle parce que eh bien
radio apal est le journal appelle ça
fait 40 ans que ça existe en martinique
vous êtes aussi faut-il rappeler
historienne on va faire un peu
d'histoire pour commencer parce que en
1981 marie-hélène des autas le paysage
audiovisuel martiniquais n'était pas du
tout celui que l'on connaît actuellement
oui alors je suis surtout là pour parler
de journal à ceux plaidant une unité je
suis directeur de publication qui a vu
le jour le 1er janvier 1980 et la radio
radio apal c'est le 6 décembre toujours
1980 un dock c'est à la fin de l'année
on va faire les quarante ans pour la
radio à coeur et c'est pas par hasard au
6 décembre c'était dimanche et c'est le
jour anniversaire du décès de frantz
fanon d'accord alors donc c'est l'année
de 1021 marque alors évidemment janvier
pour le journal et décembre pour la
radio mais je le disais 1981 en france
le paysage audiovisuel se transforme en
martinique aussi il y avait des radios
dites associative radio libre et puis on
sait qu'en 1981 c'est la gauche qui
arrive au pouvoir
françois mitterrand et le parti
socialiste en mai 1981 sont élus et ça
change la donne y compris ici en
martinique oui tout à fait radio assez
plaidant le nullité radio apal a été une
des premières radios mais la décision
avait été prise et à forts de l'élection
je ne pouvais pas deviner à l'avancé
comme françois mitterrand serait telle
est donc il ya eu ensuite une explosion
si on peut dire des radios mais ce sont
surtout jour nous disions eu des radios
musicales à allocs radio apal c'est une
radio militante de même que le journal
des bleus
nal c'est en janvier 80 françois
mitterrand n'était pas encore élu et le
journal aussi fait partie de la presse
militante et ce journal est publié et il
se vend également de façon militante
vous est la raison pour laquelle nous
devons saluer l'engagement de tous ces
militants de la première heure qui ont
participé à la rédaction à la diffusion
à la volée de ce journal et puis il faut
saluer aussi la régularité de la
publication depuis 40 ans
on va y venir avec eux peu de moyens
mais beaucoup de volontarisme
on va y venir vous disais ça c'est qu'en
fait jusqu'à maintenant d'ailleurs un
peut-être un peu moins mais le journal
se vendait effectivement dans la rue
directement auprès de la population
d'actes mans et le journal continue à se
vendre de cette façon l'essentiel bien
sûr nous avons des numéros dans les
points vote presse des listes dassault
service de librairie
mais l'essentiel de notre publication du
journal à pal se vend toujours avec des
moteurs femmes 17 heures du matin le
week-end le week-end dimanche matin
aussi offre on frappe on continue à
frapper et il y à des militants qui sont
là depuis quarante ans et qui continue à
vendre ce journal
alors à part assez pléré annou lité bon
pour ceux qui sont pas que l'ophone y
conte qui comprennent pas bien le col
bon c'est assez facile c cessons de
pleurer et puis luttons quoi mettons
nous à lutter avec todd passer notre
temps à nous plaindre à pleurnicher
le tos à dire mettons nous en situation
de prendre nos responsabilités quel que
soit le problème que nous avons à
affronter qu'ils soient climatique
qu'ils soient politiques économiques
sociales nous pouvons être en capacité
de prendre nos responsabilité de trouver
les solutions de mettre en application
mettre en oeuvre ces solutions quitte à
avoir de l'aide mais de l'aide
d'ailleurs de partout mais c'est quelque
chose que nous devons que nous pouvons
faire c'est surtout donc c'est cet
esprit là que nous avons voulu
développer à travers d'autres pratiques
mais dans un contexte politique social
économique particulier parce que c'est
un appel à la responsabilité
mais contre l'assistanat on peut le dire
comme ça aussi visée assistée exactement
contre une forme d'assistanat et là
l'apport original du journal as pas
justement dans la presse que ce soit la
presse d'information générale que ce
soit la presse militante
l'apport original ce que nous avons fait
le choix de développer une pensée
révolutionnaire face aux idées
réactionnaires
alors qu'est ce que cela veut dire
qu'est ce qu'une pensée révolutionnaire
c'est une pensée qui vous dit qu'avec
une meilleure organisation de la société
en tenant compte de des aspects positifs
dans notre histoire de notre culture est
également en utilisant tous les progrès
de la technologie des sciences et des
techniques
en ayant une société où on essaie de
répondre aux besoins réels de la
population
on peut avancer vers le progrès humain
on peut avancer vers des relations
sereines des relations équilibrées entre
les membres de la société
c'est cela une pensée révolutionnaire
aller vers ce qu'est ce que c'est les
idées réactionnaires
c'est une conception du monde qui vous
dit que par nature l'homme et en clair à
la violence qui aura toujours des
injustices qui voit toujours de la
domination dans une société et que ça
sert à rien de se battre que de lutter
contre cela c'est une pensée qui vous
dit allez choisir au mieux mais dans un
autre monde dans l'au delà
personne n'est jamais revenus et de
l'au-delà pour nous dire comment ça se
passe
nous disons que ce genre d'idées qui
conduit au fatalisme à une forme de
fatalité ce genre d'idée il faut
combattre parce que ça permet à ceux qui
sont déjà en position dominante de
continuer à dominer aussi de la société
vous savez que le premier bilan du coc
vide pour 2020 vous dit que ceux qui
étaient déjà les plus riches
ils sont sortis encore plus riche après
le qu'ovide on peut pas accepter
continuer à accepter des situations
comme ça parce que les inégalités
l'écart entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres
il grandit
à lorsqu il y à des crises comme celle
que nous vivons à la fois sanitaire
économique et social l'écart grandit on
peut pas continuer dans une caisse
sociale or donc on voit bien que c'est
un discours militant volontariste non au
fatalisme
donc on retrouve dans le journal des
articles effectivement militants mais
donc d'opinion apal c'est un journal
d'opinion et une radio d'opinion
absolument s'y croient qu'ils
participent au pluralisme de la presse
et donc voilà il ya des presses plus
généraliste et puis il ya des presse
d'opinion
et donc voilà c'est quand même
évidemment sur le plan je dirais
idéologiques de l'action politique
marquée évidemment marqué à gauche dans
le camp révolutionnaire parce que vous
êtes évidemment la radio est lié
beaucoup aux cncp aussi un mouvement les
politiques et les mouvements politiques
c'est un bon c'est ça il fallait quand
même le préciser pour ceux qui ne le ne
le sauraient pas encore vont à mon avis
et puis donc on y vient de 40 ans de
fonctionnement avec peu de moyens c'est
une association c'est ça et puis vous
avez peut-être quelques subventions et
puis des donateurs oui absolument
ce les moyens en fait ce soient les
moyens militants bon les ya pas de
journaliste professionnel
évidemment ce sont des journalistes
militants simplement bénévoles et c'est
un mensuel donc vous me direz ça ça
laisse quand même le temps
n'allez pas trouver les faits divers
dans à part parce que c'est un journal
au quotidien dont vous aurez pas les
faits au jour le jour mais vous avez
beaucoup d' analyse de réflexion vous
avez beaucoup d'articles théorique sur
ce que c'est qu'une société un moderne
est une société mieux organisés donc
c'est socialement ça mais est-ce qu'il
ya quand même un souci d'objectivité
aussi dans votre positionnement
éditorial est ce que sur l'antenne de
radio apal dans le journal est ce qu'on
peut avoir aussi quand même vous voyez
ce que je veux dire de l'expression de
notre opinion actuelle les opinions que
vous allez voir ce sont les opinions
selon la
in rédactionnelle que j'ai défini au
début développer une pensée
révolutionnaire face aux idées
réactionnaires
ceci dit les articles sont forcément
objectif
vous avez des articles les luttes des
travailleurs face à l'objectif
mais autant ça participe aussi à l'éveil
des consciences au bond la veille au
soir
la voir que seul son cloche
l'objectivité ce n'est pas la neutralité
c'est l'historienne qui vous parle
un historiés doit être objecté ça des
kilowatts les faits et il fait une
analyse à partir de faits et d'arguments
qu'il présente mais vous ne connaissait
pas destrier qui sont neutres
ça ça n'existe pas il faut pas rigoler
la presse développe soit les aider des
capitalistes soient les idées
révolutionnaires
oui oui et d'ailleurs on retrouve
quelques fois développé la thèse
évidemment de comme vous dites des
capitalistes où on développe le factuel
et puis ensuite vient donc l'analyse en
fonction de la grille de lecture
spécifique à toutes les presses même les
journaux d'informations générales
ses journaux en ligne rédactionnelle
s'ils ne le disent pas qu'il fait aux
thomas il faut être objectif parce qu'il
faut partir de faits réels mais personne
n'est neutre dans notre société alors un
aspect important aussi de 2,2 ce qui est
fait à travers l'action l'oeuvre de deux
appels radio apal est le journal c'est
ce regard sur la caraïbe alors d'une
manière générale et en particulier sur
un certain nombre de pays de la caraïbe
les expériences qui se déroule au
venezuela par exemple à cuba bolivie en
d'autres lieux voilà les expériences
révolutionnaires bien sûr vous jetez un
regard particulier sur eux oui tout à
fait lorsque vous regardez dans le reste
de la presse sauf quelques ex nous ne
sommes pas le seul journal militant en
martinique
je salue les 100 ans du journal justice
quand même mais c'est vrai mais
l'essentiel de la presse va vous parler
surtout de l'europe et de la france
nous avons fait un choix justement la
pensée révolutionnaire
nous sommes nés dans la dans le sillage
de la révolution chinoise et la
révolution cubaine
de nous de vous allez trouver des
articles au niveau international de
solidarité avec les peuples en lutte
c'est ce que vous allez trouver et
particulièrement deux pays qui sort sous
le coup de blocus venant des états unis
depuis des dizaines d'années pour cuba
vous allez trouver socialement les
luttes populaires et les réalisations de
la révolution cubaine est également du
venezuela qui a payé qui est menacé
depuis on peut dire maintenant plusieurs
années par l'épée réalisme amérique
allez on va conclure marie-hélène les
hôtes un directeur de publication de
apal pour la radio et le journal as pas
lassant à ses paires en nullité
concernant la modernisation la
transmission et puis un rendez vous
vendredi on va terminer là dessus une
conférence débat mais voilà est-ce que
c'est un organe de presse qui va
maintenant sur les réseaux sociaux à une
pour avoir une version internet voyez ce
que je veux dire est ce que voilà et et
elle relève est ce que les animateurs
les journalistes aussi si vous faites
appel à des plus jeunes
est-ce que vous formez aussi d'aider des
gens absolument forcément toute
organisation politique
toute organisation révolutionnaire va
également assurer sa relève et faire
appel aux plus jeunes
nous avons un site internet a fait c'est
le site internet de la radio ainsi radio
tiré à part le point com
et puis nous avons un rendez-vous donc
vendredi
ces données doivent être février à 18
heures à l'hôtel de la ctm plateau roy
cluny à 18 heures rue de vaux où le
thème justement c'est l'apport du
journal à ses plans en unités sur la
voie de l'émancipation du peuplement
indiqué besoin de nous sommes dit que
pour aller vers une véritable
décolonisation vers l'émancipation
il faut justement développer cette
pensée révolutionnaire pour une autre
organisation de la société vous aurez
trois intervenants et demande aux désirs
du journal as éperon en nullité il fait
partie du comité de rédaction
michel branchi je prends du journal
juste et c'est le rédacteur en chef de
justice
et puis un journaliste professionnel et
c'est adam squatter qui est président ou
haïti
ida du club pryor président du club
précise encore président et hervé voilà
donc pour ce rendez vous ce vendredi
demain 18 heures salle camille darsières
à l'hôtel de la ctm à cluny conférence
débat pour les 40 ans du journal as et
pléré annou lité en nullité l'apport des
journaux anticolonialiste dans la lutte
pour l'émancipation du peuple
martiniquais merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions bonne journée vous retrouvez
jimmy merci
[Musique]